we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we will take our next call from the 9 1
7 area code New York City caller what's
your name and where are you calling from
today I'm actually calling from Los
Angeles my name is Matt Matt what's on
your mind today I just wanted to ask
about the ideological position of the
left now that we're into trumpism and
the trump presidency do you see the
Trump presidency
consolidating the left's ideology and
you know through a resistance or
something like that
or do you see a further sort of
fracturing and splintering with the
centrist left the regressive left is
there such a thing as a cohesive left
anymore now that we're so out of power
and yeah in Trump's America so listen
there's to it there's not a there's not
a fixed answer to this so there's sort
of two forces that are impacting the
left right now one is mostly unanimous
sentiment that this is a disaster that
whatever your view about hillary clinton
was the idea that Trump and Clinton
would have been the same could not be
more wrong obviously Hillary Clinton
would not have signed orders moving
forward on undi Dakota access and
Keystone XL hillary clinton would not
have ordered all references to climate
change be removed from the white house
and epa websites etc etc etc so on the
one hand you have the idea that most
everybody on the on the reasonable left
and even on the in the center and some
center-right people are saying
trainwreck the number one priority needs
to be to allow something like a trump
presidency never to happen again on the
other side you have somewhat of a
fracturing which I described from my
visit to the Boston women's March last
weekend which is that there are those on
the Left who say hey you know what the
identity politics ideas did not work to
prevent Trump from being elected and we
need to support minority groups not by
singular focus on individual minority
groups but by a broader anti-corruption
anteye kleptocratic economic message of
broader justice right and I don't know
which force is going to win I don't know
that I would call the left fractured
although I think that there are
differences of opinion on the left in
terms of what the next step needs to be
does that make sense
yeah I mean do you think that there
needs to be a strong vocal opinion
amongst maybe Center leftist that the
social justice warrior wing of the party
the the identity politics wing of the
party needs to be like definitively
rebuked within the parties no so I know
where you're going with this and I know
that there are people a lot of people
have been emailing me and talking to me
about David isn't it time for the left
to just denounce social justice warriors
for me when someone even uses the term
social justice warrior I already want to
know more about what they even mean by
that because it's become pejorative in a
way that I think goes above and beyond
sort of my criticisms of the identity
politics focus that sometimes exists so
I don't think the left needs to denounce
those who seek social justice I won't
even call them social justice warriors I
don't think it's about denouncing them I
think it's about having a pragmatic
conversation and saying hey if you're a
progressive you care about
discrimination against minority groups
you care about individuals who because
of their identity are disproportionately
negatively affected by policy or policy
be but from a pragmatic perspective
let's create a broader more broadly
appealing way to bring people together
for action that that's as far as I would
go and how I would delineate it well I
hope that can happen all right I hope so
to really appreciate the call always
great to hear from Los Angeles